Oh  hi everyone I'm Alex bulletin I'm  glamorous fashion director at large and  today we're shooting Maya drama for a  10-page hair story which is going to be  in the big September beauty book which  is out for autumn/winter so the story is  kind of focusing on six of the biggest  hair trends for the new season  within that I've kind of chosen a  palette of rougher burgundy tomato  scarlet clothing which is going to  really offset all the hair looks that  are going on and are going to look  beautiful against my skin because it's  the color that she looks really  phenomenal in as well as all of the  clothes something that's really  important on today's Beauty shoot  because it is all about the hair is all  of the jewelry so it is really important  that we pick these kind of bold  sculptural shapes that felt a little bit  architectural graphic they just make it  feel edgy and modern and then sit with  all of those kind of minimal pared back  clothes that I'm doing as well  [Music]